junko what's your take on false
motivation versus authentic leadership
okay false motivations versus authentic
leadership now there's two kind of mmm
two kind of ways of understanding this
question the first is from like a really
heavy leadership perspective and that is
of trying to lead without actually
believing in what you're doing and
that's leading without understanding why
and not believing in what you're doing
and that's wrong right and this is an
extreme ownership of course and we
talked about on the podcast you can't do
it if you don't believe it and what
you're doing your team is gonna see that
and they won't believe in it either
which means they're not gonna go above
and beyond to accomplish the mission
period so you gotta believe what you're
doing and if you don't believe it then
you gotta ask the question up the chain
of command
find out why understand why so that you
believe in what you're doing and
eventually you're gonna get the answer
right you have enter you're gonna
understand why you're doing something
you're gonna believe in it or you're
gonna you're gonna convince the chain of
command that that's not a good method
then you need to go a different
direction and there might be some rare
in extremists case where you actually
don't you know for your I'm being told
to do something I don't believe in it
and I'd say no I'm not gonna do it in
like Napoleon said Napoleon's Maxim's if
you you you actually have to refuse to
do it if you don't believe it's the
right thing to do then you don't do it
that should be a very in extremity cuz
our as a leader when we're being asked
to do something or told to do something
or lead in a certain way they're leading
us towards victory right they're leading
us towards an aligned victory if it's on
the battlefield it's winning the war if
it's in business it's creating profit
and creating a good product and and
growing the business right those things
are that's what you're trying to do
so if echo if I if I'm the boss and you
come to me with a with something and say
hey I want to do this if it's gonna make
us more profitable why would I say no
right
we're gonna move in that direction um so
from a high level false motivation
doesn't work if you don't believe in
something it's not gonna work out for
you now from a micro level from like a
frontline level and the buds instructors
used to joke about this that false meta
motivation is better than no motivation
have you ever heard that is that a
common expression false motivation is
better than no motivation and we don't
want that to be true right because we
want motivation to be this pure golden
thing that fuels performance but the
fact of the matter is and of course we
talk about all this all the time
motivation doesn't hold up right
motivation doesn't know how many
motivated people motivated people didn't
make it through single training a ton of
them they're all motivated how many of
them didn't make it for training on how
many motivated people do you see that
don't accomplish their goals that they
have Yeah right the world is full full
of those people there's a ton of those
people yeah and that's because
motivation doesn't hold you up we all
know this it's discipline that holds you
up it's discipline that gets things
going and it's discipline that gets you
through things but this is a little
interesting little spin if you have the
discipline to press on wanna have a
little fun with it right and that's
where I think false motivation can come
in and you can make some things fun for
instance it's cold wet and miserable and
we have to go swim over the beach and do
an operation let's get some ice or it's
118 degrees with massive humidity and we
have a 14 kilometer patrol to get to
target let's get some whoo yeah or the
water is 41 degrees and we are about to
launch on a four hour dive right hell
yes let's do this right that that's
false motivation but it's backed up by
discipline and it might not be real but
it absolute
beats the hell out of this is gonna be
miserable if I don't want to do it right
what would you if you and I were gonna
go do something that was gonna suck
would you rather have me say echo I
really don't want to do this but I'm
disciplined so I'm gonna do it would you
have rather have me say echo this is
gonna suck
let's go get something right you better
have the false motivation yes sir
strap on the pack and put on the mask
and fins and fire up the false
motivation here after it now I will tell
you this I wouldn't even be sarcastic
with false motivation I won't even blink
in an accent like this is the difference
my false motivation isn't even false I
actually believe my own false motivation
yeah and by the time stuff came out of
my mouth I meant it I I meant it so I
don't know at some point in my childhood
false motivation turned into like an
actual fuel and just just regular
motivation maybe it's cuz I realized
that I wasn't counting on it to get me
through things I was just having fun
with it
rock and roll do you think also how you
know you like you'd always say that
you're kinda into just being hard core
it's like normal stuff whatever so you
know when you think back and you're like
okay I'm gonna take the hard route or
whatever after you finish it you kind of
feel more proud of it first like do you
think that that played into it yeah that
is like I can beat ya for sure for sure
be more hardcore yeah yeah like like I
said like the meaning of the meaning of
the music hardcore when I was a kid was
being hardcore just the actual meaning
of the word and so yeah it's real easy
to go from that to like hey I'm gonna do
something that sucks and I'm gonna have
a good time with I'm gonna laugh about
it yeah
and then it is contagious so contagious
I'm actually know like that now and if
where'd you say you're gonna like no I'm
actually like that now oh okay not too
you know hundred percent but in a lot of
things been like my um my daughter she's
four she weighs 45 47 pounds so I'll be
sitting or it'll all be laying on the
couch not paying attention she'll climb
up on the couch behind and jump in land
like you know what a knee drop Israel
Tomic
drop yes just so you know for a while in
my house there was no rules in my house
no actually there was no there was only
two rules in my house when my kids were
like when my older kids were like you
know seven six
whatever that those types of ages that
your daughter's out right now but a
little bit older there was two rules in
my house number one don't touch me when
I'm eating
number two no atomic need drops they
would do it to each other oh yeah they
might never do it to me but they would
atomic me drop each other yeah so I had
to have two rules I'm plus I wouldn't
have a lot of time to eat and all of a
sudden it's like they want to hold on my
arm no no no no no get away from you
when I'm eating like a like a rabid dog
and it's funny one of them the reason
that's fresh in my mind cuz we were just
on a trip and and you know my kids were
explaining to my youngest daughter that
well you know when we were little dad
was meaner and he wouldn't let us touch
him when we were when he was eating like
you just did and of course I said well
that's because she's cuter than usual
all of you I don't mind that time at
knee drops anymore because of you
because of the very reason like you
gotta be hardcore it's cuz they okay you
got a four-year-old kid Yeah right
so how fun that is for her to it's Oh
drop you yeah which is another reason
why I'm like this now so so climb on the
couch a tiny drop while I'm not ready by
the way onto my ribs so she didn't break
my ribs she didn't injure me to any
blasting degree but if the normal mind
said is like why did you jump why did
you do that they'd hurt ya let's face it
45 47 pounds top of a couch Tomic knee
drop both knees by the way all the way
velocity all that stuff hurt by the
normal standard of things
so the typical mindset I think would be
like don't do that especially the shock
and on this earth but default is just
like whatever no factor yeah Harger and
yeah sure it is a catch-22 because she
will and does and but she thinks it's
all fun and all this stuff but yeah
that's that mindset and that came
directly from you like Bri it's like
who wouldn't complain about that right
there you let that happen
yeah it's really embarrassing if you
complain to your four-year-old about
anything
you hurt about anything yeah right about
anything that's that that's the setting
example you were talking about earlier
yeah you complain about anything and
you're wrong
agree so just suck it up yeah say bring
it on yeah false motivation which
becomes real motivation which for be
hardcore the only like I said the only
sort of reason for motivation for me is
just funny just funny it's not gonna
actually get you to do anything but just
let's have fun I'm gonna do it anyways
I'm gonna let the atomic knee drops
happen over and over again and I'm gonna
and so why when I could go through life
just experiencing them and accepting
them one I have some fun with the atomic
knee drops and the long cold dives and
those hot weather and the you know
dehydration and the hypothermia why not
have fun with all those things yeah and
I mean you probably know but it's
unbelievable how much that helps
yourself you know what I think maybe
because my view of motivation is so low
yeah that to me it's just funny yeah
like false motivation like just funny
yeah and it but it is fun yeah it's a
fun thing yeah that's kind of part of
what I mean kay so that you know the
mats I don't know if you noticed I
brought the mats yes so those mats
they're I think just like sixteen of
them I forget how many but they cover a
two full two-car garage covers it
perfectly it's a lot a lot of Max and
the two inch thick ones so to move them
you know up the you know the topography
is that even so you had so you I'd like
some legit challenges came in put the
mats right there boom one day I don't
know whenever the other day and then you
know I walked to Jade's office my
brother you know you think oh hey what
are you doing here I was like oh I just
put the mats in here he's like you put
the mats in here what do you do you what
did someone help you with that I looked
at me and I said I don't need help
oh but it was a joke because that's the
line from this thing but um
but the point there is just that that
attitude you know like no I don't need
help no I don't you know cuz I'm trying
to be like Jocko you know I don't need
help
it hurt me you know it's like that
mindset but it said is chaim you're
turning into a complete savage but sweet
little kids can't hurt you and you can
carry the mats by your own yeah and
their own that's another thing this is
another little expressionist because my
son when he was cook before he could
talk well he would see you would want to
do something eat a lemon you'd say I do
it by my own by myself or on my own that
makes it by my oh that became a thing
here's a legitimate one that that just
changed it changed this specific thing
where you know how I'd like I'd be the
kind of fighting getting enough sleep I
just I'd let it ruin me mentally so if I
didn't have something specifically
important to do so just throughout the
day hell I'm tired you know whatever so
now I never admit that I'm tired yeah
that's a good great starting place yeah
I've you know I've explained that to my
son is is you just don't admit ever that
don't let those words come out of your
mouth yeah tired I'm sore I'm whatever
just just stop are you getting the
team's you that's just that's just a
putting up a red flag of being a
complete pansy don't do it don't do it
as a matter of fact you know what's
jacked up is like I won't even let's see
you and I were to go out let's say was
wintertime and you and I were to go out
and I had a sweatshirt with me mmm-hmm
because I knew it might get cold
right but what Howard already and I have
this sweatshirt oh my god you can't put
it on I won't even put it on can't put
it on because any then you might say
well you called I think I've told this
story before
room time we're driving from LA it was
like late at night and you're like yeah
I know I'm this big bad team guy or
whatever but I'm kind of tired right now
and then almost like you just it was
painful to let the words out of your
mouth you know like
let him slip and it really hurt you it
was like maybe like three seconds later
[__] it I'll just drive to Montana if I
have to right now
I was tired yesterday I was driving and
I and my wife says like are you haven't
been sleeping much are you okay to drive
I was like yeah and I actually did the
same thing I was kinda like well I'm
super tired
I can drive indefinitely I mean you I
don't know maybe you're different maybe
not but no no I don't encourage people
doing that yeah don't encourage it
that's a that's a horrible thing to do
is drive when you're actually prett
yeah yeah don't do that well uncle I
it's it's happened before but Uncle I
it's really boring to drive it's so easy
it's just so like you don't so when you
get like tired or sleepy or whatever
it's really easy to just fall asleep
super easy and that's hard because you
can't control it it's like I think you
can just I can control it ensure there's
little tactics there looking like do
little things that you know inflict pain
on yourself whatever but man it's really
hard to control once you follow see I
know don't do that don't think that you
wake up in a bridging moment just yeah
dad or wake up that yeah yeah that is
not good
the I was reading this thing on
motivation and it said in this book I'm
not saying that this is true or not true
but it's said I made sense where
motivation people misuse the word
motivation and they confuse it with
inspiration so inspiration is like when
someone gets you all revved up to do
something right like what you know let's
do this or you see a mansion now you're
inspired to work hard for stuff or
whatever listen to some speech some
quote-unquote motivational speech it
inspires it doesn't motivate you
motivation is your your your bare raw
motive the motive for you doing it so
let's say I feel like I said this before
but the let's say I want to get in shape
you know girls will get in shape for
their wedding mm-hmm you know that's the
motive is to be in shape for the wedding
okay so that doesn't go away so she's
not necessarily inspired meaning she's
like she got infused with some feeling
yeah you know
just like motivation wouldn't go away
but it would well it no he's gonna get
her there is disciplined yeah yeah the
motivation she wakes up at five o'clock
in the morning to go get a workout and
of course she goes to work but it's real
easy to just be like you know what I'm
not feeling motivated today right right
I'll just get the get the wedding dress
you know let out a little bit yeah but
that just means that the motive
motivation the motive isn't strong
enough to overcome her feeling their
lack of you I don't rely on it yeah
you're not gonna find a motivation
that's strong enough to make you do the
things that you have to do all the time
you don't you can't doesn't exactly it
kind of well it depends it just depends
so consider a fighter
stop consider a fighter with a fight he
has to make weight bro yeah you're right
guys don't make exactly that's what I'm
saying though the motive and you know
what you know where that you know when
that motivation failed that motivation
failed you know five weeks yeah when
they should win their life guys burgers
yeah they had a Five Guys Burgers yeah
you're right so this one holds the line
yeah it does totally now you can have
fun with it and you can be motivated to
have discipline and you can say oh like
Pete Robin from origin geese I was up
with him in Maine and he's like got a
bet to lose weight and he hit me with
some false motivation because we were
out we were out and you know we were
horn I was awarded big skate and just
getting after the grub sir and I said
like how many more pounds you have you
know we're talking about how that goes
it kind of sucker said here is that no I
actually enjoyed watching you eat
delicious food no false motivation
coming at you but in a funny way yeah
and instead of letting it out like that
instead of being just miserable why not
just have some fun with it yeah yeah
there's my advice yeah fully but then
the difference though like I said I
agree you're right I mean I the point I
was maybe making was a was just the
technical difference between motivation
and inspiration
no because both those words just there's
a wager yeah they're weak words and
their weekend and the actual subjects
are weak inspiration Oh
like it's not gonna get you there come
on it might get you through like a the
first three minutes of you know you and
I were just talking before you came in
here you said there was moments in your
workout today when you put it in easily
or yesterday I could have easily called
it like hey man I'm sweating I got a
good workout but ya didn't yeah you held
the line yes
discipline discipline it was actually I
created falsehood it just truth be told
you're right but I've created false
motivation for myself I say you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna do this
actually it's the way for me to
facilitate discipline for myself is I
want to do this because I'm gonna feel
better afterwards oh yes so that whole
do you're talking about this then you
contrast it with how junk I'm gonna
wheel if I don't week embarrassed for
myself by the way
and when I said that um you know how
workout has many opportunities to stop
yeah so one the first opportunity is in
the parking lot in this case I went to a
gym so bro if you walk away when you're
in the parking lot you got issues so
I've done that I've done that like four
times I may have to admit that on the
podcast you should just lie
what makes this current story okay more
significant so boom that's the first
opportunity second opportunities before
you warm up which is pretty close to the
first offer cut off before you won't be
ever quit then yes oh my god Weiss one
time it felt real good because I
justified it very effectively in the
second time I was like I just got to get
after it tomorrow whatever nonetheless
then then it's after the first body part
or the first sorta you know you have I'm
gonna do you know MEK on first I'm gonna
do spots first so you know it's after
the first exercise body part really yeah
yeah okay that's one of these like to me
the biggest hurdle is getting there oh
yeah which is when you have your gym
your house that's that totals gone I
agree that it gets easier
um to hold the line for sure after you
start but there's a part at the end you
know I like how you just said you'd like
to do your megwin like yeah afterwards
no lately I've been doing metcon before
and lifting heavy affright right yeah
that's what a message but you're right I
could say you know what that met come
was a little bit heavy yeah we just call
it good oh yeah
the heavy part yeah exactly right man I
feel so good when I'm all loosened up
yeah yeah so same deal with me and I uh
you know every opportunity to quit was
past it was waived well done that go
charlie